we've just been giving such killer
vocals all night I'm worried that we're
going to melt the audience's faces
off merry Christmas
everybody I feel very overdress
meate oh my God one of my best friends
has got a Christmas
[Music]
special hey guys Hannah wam calling I am
here at the Glorious London Coliseum to
record my Christmas special Hannah
waddingham Home For Christmas on Apple
TV plus Miss wam to Stage please why
singing
car right outside my
door all these things are more baby all
these things are more my baby that's
what
[Applause]
christas the London Coliseum has been my
home since I was 8 years old my mom
started in the chorus here it has always
held such a place in my heart and and
now I'm fronting my own show here what I
would have given to do this show in a
pair of
[Laughter]
[Music]
Birkenstocks I was so excited to get the
most glorious people involved it's
amazing to be part of this family it's
so cool and Christmas is all about
family right what is we're all here
because we love you and we think you're
amazing a lot of Christmas elves running
around just sprinkling their Christmas
magic
it's quite mad there's a lot going on
lots of kind of choreography and flying
rehearsals this is a lifelong dream for
her and I couldn't be more proud of this
woman and I can't believe she asked me
to be a part of it I'm your Christmas
miracle I have a beautiful mixture of
Friends The Fabulous Lounge swingers
please welcome the London gay men's
chorus and Global Stars Mr Leslie Odin J
Hannah you are making everybody proud
today and so happy so full of joy thank
you for this special please welcome Luke
Evans Hannah my love I've known you for
a very long time and it's just a joy to
be on a stage with you tonight Merry
Christmas Sam
Ridder you embody such a spirit of the
craft it's a total honor my
friend hell just seeing all these
different Worlds Collide you know people
in the audience the people on stage it's
the very best of times with the very
best people we're going to support each
other for the rest of our lives we are
we are and this is a big deal it
is thank you for letting us all be a
part of it it's a a dream country Hannah
congratulations on achieving your dream
was
lovely Hannah we love you you're going
to smash it as usual Christmas and
thanks for having us I'm feeling quite
Christmasy are you this whole experience
has been the greatest Pinch Me moment it
was an utter utter pipe
dream thank you from my sparkly
[Applause]
[Music]
heart